course these days the news can feel well
let's face it overwhelming
it's nice sometimes to mix it up and
have a little bit of fun
with things that are happening in the
news that's why we have a very special
guest who does
just that this guy's been gently skewing
politics for decades with his unique
blend of light satire
and ragtime piano music your parents
probably have some of his old records
like
politics phooey and hitting below the
beltway
yeah this guy's great please welcome
political song
paradist tip rivers
hello conan it's great to see you again
it's great to see
anybody these days what a mess am i
right
don't get me started okay i won't yeah i
know what you mean 2020 has been a rough
year
which is why i'm excited to hear your
satirical take on the news
through the power of piano music well
i'll do my darn best
how about a little ditty about the
current occupant of 1600
pennsylvania avenue oh boy song about
trump okay great here we go
okay here we go oh
donald trump is the president of the usa
and when joe biden is in jail in the
white house
trump will stay with a fraud fraud here
and a steel steel there we must find
biden's crimes and lock him up to the
end of time so
donald trump stays president as god
intended
so don't get me started
okay i i have to say that's not the song
i expected
oh well you sound like me when i found
out that biden won
georgia not what i expected are you
kidding me come on the machines had to
have flipped votes
okay tip your songs in the old days they
were more balanced and nuanced are you
getting all your news from like fox and
newsmax
what those radical leftist supplicants
no way
if you want the real truth you've got a
dig and that's why i get all my news now
from this great website called
christiannewspatriot.truth
would you like to hear another uh you
know only if you can just tone it down a
bit okay
you would like me to tone it down shall
i tone it down here or tone it all the
way down here
[Music]
that's just a little musical fun but i
take your meaning very little yeah oh
you'll like this one this one
is long on laughs and light on
politics great here we go it can't be
debated kovit's death rate is inflated
it's a big
hoax the vaccines were designed to help
bill gates control our minds
hey hey hey can you just not please
don't sing songs like that
really well i was a little flat wasn't i
is that your objection it's been a
little while since i was allowed to
perform
publicly let's try another okay
oh yankee doodle went to town and was
murdered by auntie
no no no no no no definitely not that
one
well tip do you have any songs that have
absolutely nothing to do with politics
at all
absolutely yes i do something for the
normies who haven't been red pilled yet
is that what you have in mind
that's fine how about this a sweet
little christmas tune yeah the christmas
tune here we go
no problem at all oh we
wish you a merry christmas we wish you a
merry christmas
we wish you a merry christmas and the
cia did
9 11. don't get me started on that
you want to tell me the jet fuel can
melt steel
okay tip rivers everybody thank you twin
thank you
thank you yet to hear a coherent
explanation of why building seven went
down
all right that was a controlled
explosion we have a great
show joe manganello's with us uh he's
gonna be joining us
and uh he was in on it tip
he was part of the whole thing he
designed the holograms for the twin
towers
no it's not a hologram there's no way it
could have been a hologram they keep
suppressing the video